ketchup mustard Oh sausages and buns  happy  maybe I can't be  datastream boys Hey look at this with  that one yes we're chosen hey Brenda you  and me I'm so happy that God's better  packages together because we belong  together it's like we were made for each  other get ready boys ah feels amazing oh  yes find the first to enter eternity way  to go  the peeps that types are come in  in children so you have learned the  terrible truth I gotta tell everyone  everything we believe is a lot but  they're doing this to us because we  touch tips I mean it was fine it's not  like anyone writes home and says oh god  I had the best tip shake what your momma  hey I am sorry I accidentally dropped a  few things back there I'm gonna fix you  I'm gonna fix this  hey boys hey look at this with that one  yes  we're chosen together